ゴンちゃんと弾み社長です我々チューバーコメントなんというものがありましてですね
まぁ動画を出すとその動画にコメントをできる場所がありましてこの動画をスマホで見
てる方いるとこうやって画面をスワイプしていってくださいコメントがあると思います
まぁ基本的にはなんですけどもあの輸注バーって皆さんコメントを気にしていると思う
んですよ
多分まあまあ
雨なぁもうここもゆチューバー約7年くらいやってるんで
7年くらいやるとちょっとまあちょっとねちょっと気にしないかなったんですけども
動画によってはめちゃくちゃコメントが気になったり
まあこれどう思われてるんだろうという動画を上げた時のハンドとすごい気になったり
するんですよお酒なんですけどもユーチューバーは人に動画を見てもらいたいと思って
て動画を出してると
ホンデパスはなれども反響とか皆の意見とかコメントが気になっていると思うんですよ
ねその中約7年間ユーチューバーやってきた私をはじめ出走を選んだ
ってか何なら今から選ぶここ最近言われて悲しかった
コメントベスト5を紹介したいと思いますなんで嬉しいコメントじゃなくて悲しい
コメントかっていうと
[音楽]
書かれた気ないからででは行こうよはいどけど実際にコメント見ていきましょうか
まあでもね最近ででそんな中ひどい悪口とかね批判コメントあんまり見てないと思うん
ですよね
[音楽]
あーありましたねぇ別にこのコメントで良い悪いじゃなくて純粋に悲しくなるコメント
というともったいないってコメントがよく来ますね
あの言わせてください
もったいなくはないと思いますこれなぜかと言いますと僕タピオカがないとたでこの
動画ですよ
大量のタピオカを床に置いてる動画なんですけどこれもったいないって言い出すと動画
が撮れなくなるんですよなぜかというとこの動画に必要なものなんだと思いますか
そう大量のタピオカが必要なんですとなるとあのわかんないけどもしこれが僕動画回せ
なくてね個人的にプライベートでやってたらそりゃもちろん僕はもったいないと思い
ますし
どう見てももったいないタピオカがもったいないってなるんですけどた票顔ああいう
使い方することによって1本の動画ができてるわけですから
うんかもったいない
のかなって思っちゃいますは彼にそういう人それぞれです
あくまで私の意見として受け止めておいてくださいもったいねちょっとあのでも悲しい
ですそれをそう使わないとできないことが多いんでない良い財布をなくし制定イラッと
するって言う6日はれるんですけど多分一番イラッとしているな
僕ですこれちょっとあのまあしょうがないですよねこんな下さいこーなーぐっと早速に
いいねやばいと思いますこんなにもなくセット注意力の三男差が大きすぎると思うん
ですけども
本当にあの僕も気をつけようと思っておりますで多分なんですけど先に行ってきます
またなくします毛氈適所といってことですからまたなくすんでネタだと思ってみて
ください動画の中の僕は超
を当てていると思うんですけどでもちょっとはなくずゲームを自分の中で大体分かって
て慢性的な世民不足とぜってー何かやってるんですよスマホのゲームに熱中しているか
動画の編集してるからなんか考え事するからもうず分の中である程度原因はわかってる
んですけどもどうしようもないっていうのはあっ
gps 移動しなくそうとしているわけじゃないんですけどもなくしてしまったときは
どうが点って思ってるんで今後ももし僕が最高な草際は
他人事だと思って払ってあげてくださいっていうのは容易ですかねぇ
第3位見つけました発想が天才
[音楽]
だがうまくいかない
はーい
ます o なんですよ
そうなんだけどしか言えやりたいことでが思い次はちょっとだけ変わってるなと思うん
ですけどもそれだけなんですよねそれがうまくいくとかちょっと
正直よくわかんないじゃなくいってもうまくいかなくても動画にしちゃってるんで
ちょっとその結果うまくいかないことが多いね実験とか検証とかすると食べてうまく
いかないような印象がついてるのかなと思いますね
と寂しいかなでもコメントありがとうまさにこのバッグ最強の磁石をボルトゴールに
つければ100%入るんじゃねってやつがそういうコメントがありましたね
まあこれありますねあの次 a deer を上げてる人の前にめちゃくちゃ多いって
ドッキリし過ぎどうかがあったんですけどもそちらのコメントになりました
こっちら経営の本当にです
縦目により第一君とかに仕掛けた方が反応面白い
ゲージがターゲットのが圧倒的に面白いまず秒閉店前でやりましょう
縦目んじゃない人に行ってほしかったなぁ
ni
俺じゃなくてねこれは俺皿22手目が悲しいコメントだなってことを持つあるん
女ってコメントある自由なんでで何書いてもいいと思うんですよ正直これはこの乳中
バーガーがそのコメントどうかっていうの僕がただの徒然と話せるだけなんですけど
エリア仕掛けた人形てメンって言うんですけども彼の気持ちからするとこんな他の人の
ほうが良かったほかの人の子か
あげてくださいと言われて悲しいと思うんですけど僕からするとですよどうだを作った
僕からするとあの a には沢山置いてに起きないのは彼だけなんですよ
あの子眠りがすごい深いので寝起きドッキリできるのはもう立て女しかいないのであの
僕ドッキリ仕掛けるといっしょ適材適所で絶対この人がいいなとかこういったちゃんと
できないなといろいろ考えた上でチョイスしてるんで
そんな裏事情なんでみなさんもちろんわからないと思うんですけどなんか他の人が
良かったとかあの人がリアクション絶対面白いとか言うと
まあ人の意見なにそれはそれでいいかなと思うんですけど
書かれた本人は辛いんじゃないかなって
思います別に何書いてもいいですけどね何書いてもいいんですけど純粋なぽくなっ
ちゃうんですよねのほうがいいねのほうが良かったなにねぇんじゃなくてねにして
くださいとかっていうのって
うーん
ちょっと悲しいよねそして栄えある第一章を時期にこいつは悲しいなってもコメントは
昔のほうが良かったというコメントですホーローいい
いやそれまあまあまあそうでしょうねだって昔は
アバル jeda のないろいろ炎上をするような内容とかの動画を出してたんです
けど昔の方が好きだれてもこちら凸しってなるん
象することもできるのですよね悲しい2話ですけど昔の方が好きっていう方はあります
それはそうなんでしょうって思うけど僕は昔は昔で昔の肇社長の良さがあるし今は今で
いろんな人が増えたり昔と比べるとですよ昔の方がいろんなことができたりし高もスレ
ないんですけれども今は今でまぁ
できないことも増えましたけど逆に今だからこそできることも増えたと思うんで
昔の予算は今の良さもあるんでしょアンジェなんですけど昔の方が好きとかと言われる
とですね
正直どうしようもできねーなって思いますね
そういう方はぜひあの僕たくさん頭がだしてませんで昔の動画をご覧くださいって感じ
です
昔っぽい動画もちろんで
データもしんないと思うけど僕は昔に戻れないんで僕が辺がしつつ今後音が出して
いこうと思いますのでよろしくお願い致します it 感じの水ですねあの正直製品で
素敵なコメントというか面白いコメントを読んでて悲しくなる米ないがとっても少ない
んでなかなかちょっとに難しかったなって思うんですけど
最終的に私何が言いたいかといいますとコメント10
自由だラっていう意見があると思うんですよコメントって自由だろという意見
また者にコメントは自由だし何書いてもいいし思ったことを書いてもいいと思うんです
けどまぁそれってなんか最低限の
なんか人間としての気持ちの配慮っていうのがまず第一に前提であるなってめっちゃ
硬いこと言ってんな俺めっちゃ硬いとあるんですけどもうちょっと言わせてください
僕が今回紹介したポイントは全然
僕はあの ok だと思いますソングライナーがズバズバ言われた方がユーチューバー
がお母さんをちょっとなんか嬉しいし全然歯が ok だと思いますただ悲しいものは
悲しいです失敗しちゃう人とかいるんですよ
ユーチューバーさん僕もそういうときあったんですけどね
ってなんかそういう人に呈する意見とかね何か着いたところコメント楽見てるといくら
人だと言ってもちょっとう
中といくら顔が出ないからって言いすぎでしょっていうのをたターン
あるなと思いましてまあなんかこういう動画の際に今一度
もしコメント欄で心ないことを書いてる人がいたらちょっと1回考えてみて欲しいなっ
て思いました
2世にちょっと自由を履き違えてる人がいる僕の動画だと最近特にないんですけど他の
炎上されている方のコメント欄とか見るとちょっとコメントの自由意見のずっ
というのをはき違えている方がいるのかなってたまに思いますねまぁねっとり手足って
いうもんだんですけどなーすげー真面目ぶったりいいやつ振るようなこというと
コメント欄もですね
動画とかなんか温かく楽しいパであれば嬉しいなっているか思います以上悲しい
コメントんてぃでしたーー
べ全切り世代所ねー
me
ええええええ
バッハ